hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander today we're checking out the
trailer from elimination the secret life
of pets know nothing about this movie
but I hear it's cute and adorable
alrighty
yeah I love cute cute and adorable fits
my seconds right I believe they did
minions and Despicable Me I'm pretty
sure it's to be cute it has to be cute
and a little since a knee Hey hey Jay
any plans today yes big big stuff today
Gidget I got big plans I'm gonna sit
here and I'm gonna wait for Katie to
come back oh that sounds exciting well I
won't interrupt I've got a very busy day
too
I sweeten see if you know everyone
put it in your butt
you can't good boy Leonard
cute man that was adorable I love pets I
really do love pets I was waiting for
someone to make a movie like that like
what pets do when you're not around
it's like Toy Story but with pets it
looks great what I love about these guys
is their animation tends to add to the
kind of humor they have like they kind
of snap easy nice they got going on
there really good comedic timing and I
feel like they really paid attention to
certain kind of pets to see like their
personalities and how they move and how
they like smile and stuff no there's a
lot of attention to detail here that
really like and I think her they said
louis c.k wasn't it I heard his voice at
first I liked the system of a down song
and I think a song is called bounce and
that was some funny [ __ ] funny [ __ ] I
made my day I really want a pet man I
really want a pet you should get one
once I had my bunny Ronny I felt late
more happy kids you just brightened my
day with this cute that pets boring it's
a boring pet no not I could get a good
one good wine over that sucks let me
think what kind of pet would Ryan have a
cheetah humping dog a dog that just
humps everything I feel like you'd find
that really yeah that's all at one if I
can't satisfy my woman I send in the dog
no that is no I'm gonna call the dog
Greg Alba yeah I mean it doesn't tell
you what the plot is I don't know I like
the voice actors involved like these
creators louis c.k i don't recall him
doing an animated movie ever but i
wonder if he like was able to bring his
own creativity to the table rather than
just doing the dialogue because louis
c.k is ya know he's definitely my
favorite stand-up comic so that already
alone has sold me on this film I mean a
lot of comedians end up doing a lot of
improv with these sort of films and they
kind of just add the animation in so
hopefully that's what he did
I hope so Sally for your sake
comedy's no for your sick anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to the real rejects you can
subscribe to the real rejects you check
out salamander Sally's Channel fun stuff
on there sometimes depressing stuff but
overall it's fun and you false on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter and vine
because if we get enough followers we
can get product placement or should I
say more product placement the seizure
is Zapata high um he actually sent us a
very long message kid is not the
happiest right now for understandable
reasons but a few things I can divulge
he is a big Batman fan in Star Wars and
he has a collection that's worth over 5
grand that's so cool and he is going
through tough times but we make him
laugh I won't divulge any secrets about
you even though we know everything even
though we know everything now thank you
he has genital herpes sorry that that is
not true guys he has genital herpes no
and it's it's a good kind of genital
herpes it's the kind that when you get a
woman pregnant with genital herpes if
you get a woman pregnant with it the boy
comes out with a 6-pack and so a zero
has the right sperm the right kind of
genital herpes you made this awkward for
us because we can't read your comment no
don't say that don't know you made this
awkward buddy all I'm saying is hang in
there
yeah hang in there we love you I love
you and impregnate as many woman as you
can leave your legacy behind this is Meg
C legacy